[Música]
[Aplausos]
en abril del año pasado estaba muy
sentada acá en un aula de esta
universidad
decidió atravesar junto a mis compañeros
un año bisagra en nuestra formación como
ingeniero
estamos convencidos
al terminar con los nueve meses de
carrera que nos quedaban por delante
y vamos a comernos el mundo
cumplí el sueño del éxito
y hasta cambiar parte de la realidad
aunque suene disparatado
además la gente a nuestro alrededor
decía que por fin dejaríamos de pasar
días y días fin de semana tras fin de
semana encerrados estudiando
y que vamos a lograr todo lo que nos
promocionamos
vamos a ser exitosos llenamos de plantas
y muchos otros disparates y nos llaman
que presentarnos como unos superhéroes
hoy más de un año después puedo jugar
leyes
no nos hemos implantado no nos
consideramos exitosos
y mágicamente el mundo el mundo cambia
nosotros
nos dio unos cuantos los bajos para
hacer más caer con los pies sobre la
tierra porque no éramos superhéroes sino
sólo unos cuantos negros con buenas
intenciones
les pido que imaginen por un segundo la
siguiente situación
piensen que salen de su casa como
cualquier día
y al ir caminando por la calle tiene un
accidente porque de repente no pueden
hablar caminar comer
bueno esto fue lo que le pasó a leandro
hace casi dos años
apenas una semana después de empezar la
cruzada estábamos preparando a nuestra
tesis de fin de carrera y nos cruzamos
con la historia de este joven de 17 años
leandro muy impactado con un auto quería
un fuerte golpe en la cabeza por lo que
terminó internado
cuando se despertó tenía sus capacidades
cognitivas y motrices muy disminuye
es decir tenía un poco de capacidad para
razonar y moverse por sus propios medios
por todo esto tuvo que empezar un
tratamiento de neurorehabilitación
como ninguno de nosotros tenía
conocimientos de medicina lo primero que
hicimos fue investigar de qué se trataba
todo esto cómo se hacía este tratamiento
empezamos a visitar el instituto de
rehabilitación al que asiste leandro y
nos encontramos con una situación
bastante compleja tanto para los
pacientes como para los profesionales de
la salud que los asistían por un lado
los pacientes tienen que recuperar su
capacidad de almacenamiento haciendo a
mano y en papel ejercicios de sopa de
letras sin dramas autodefinidos
y también ejercicio físico para
recuperar su movilidad protección su
equilibrio
todos estos ejercicios que hacían una y
otra vez resultaban aburridos y tedioso
para el paciente cuando tenían que
hacerlos en papeles
y por otro lado a medida que los
pacientes avanzaban con los ejercicios a
los médicos se les juntaban al final del
día pilas de miles de papeles para
conducir
más allá del evento road o tenemos que
revisar todos los ejercicios no tenían
herramientas para medir realmente el
grado de avance
y bueno a raíz de todo es lo que vivimos
y creyéndonos unos grandes visionarios
decidimos construir un producto de apoyo
para terapias de neurorrehabilitación
los pacientes podrían interactuar
haciendo ejercicios y avanzar en sus
terapias
mientras que su familia y sus médicos
podrían supervisar en tiempo real cómo
avanzan en su recuperación
esta idea consistía en unos aparatos
inalámbricos de este tamaño que
representarán colores números letras
formas
y le permitirán
al interactuar con una dinámica lúdica
más de juego para avanzar en su
tratamiento
y bueno todo esto no son muy lindos y
así fue como lo presentamos como
propuesta de tesis a nuestros docentes
ellos nos aplaudieron con bombos y
platillos dijeron bueno bárbaro cuatro
meses queremos ver esto funcionando
obviamente esto para cinco futuros
ingenieros fue más fácil
bueno
realia no tanto nos volvimos locos para
llegar con los tiempos y las
herramientas que teníamos a mano
a medida que avanzamos visitamos otros
institutos de rehabilitación para contar
cómo podíamos mejorar estos tratamientos
y al mismo tiempo participamos de
convocatoria competencias de innovación
y tecnología presentamos nuestro
producto de cara a jueces estar dos
fondos de inversión bueno nos perdimos
con los iluminados pues les dijo pero
luego que no
y nos hizo replantear nuestra idea
nuestro proyecto
y sin exagerar nuestra carrera entera
en uno de los institutos que visitamos
le mostramos nuestro producto a martín a
una adolescente que también había tenido
un accidente de tránsito
martina tenía su movilidad muy reducida
apenas movía un dedo
no hablábamos pero capacidad de
razonamiento estaba intactas
a través de una tablet con la que se
comunicaba nos dijo algo como
me gustó mucho usar el tono
es más divertido que lo que hago acá
pero ustedes que van a estar con esto
quieren venderlo por todos lados y
llenas de plata
porque a mí ya mi familia no creo que
nos alcance para comprarlos pero a otros
estos chicos les haría muy bien usarlos
para pasarla mejor mientras recuperamos
en ese momento nos miramos con mi
compañero y nos quedamos unidos se hizo
un silencio
martina rompió la atención del ambiente
diciendo que soy yo la que no puede
hablar
dibujó una sonrisa en la cara
en ese momento no supimos que
contestarle porque nunca nadie nos había
hecho esa pregunta pero nos dimos cuenta
que ya estábamos haciendo lo que nos
gustaba
esa pregunta
cómoda y sorpresiva
de carreras
queríamos terminar con una catarata de
premios y funciones teníamos llenamos de
plata
y ganas no nos falta
pero nos dimos cuenta que era otra cosa
que promovía para armar estos aparatos
día tras día las noches de las navas
era lograr que quienes
había perdido tu capacidad de leer
escribir de hablar de moverse pudiéramos
lo estamos
creíamos posibles devolverlos a mucha
gente la calidad de vida que tenía antes
de accidentes por bueno y eso la alemana
completaba todo lo demás era de
laterales largos igual de felices por el
camino al metro vídeo
hoy nuestra idea se transformó en un
producto de apoyo para terapias de
neurorrehabilitación durante los
próximos seis meses se va a probar en un
instituto que atiende a más de 50
pacientes por día
para validar que realmente ayuda
ha mejorado estos tratamientos y poder
así ampliarlo a otros institutos
queremos saludar esto que hicimos de
otra forma en un negocio rentable
pero siempre teniendo presente es
posible emprender un negocio exitoso que
genere un impacto social
y fundamentalmente queremos que este
impacto que logramos no fue casualidad o
no fue solo mérito nuestro
queremos que nada de esto hubiese sido
posible si no contábamos con la
posibilidad de estudiar en una
universidad pública
formando vamos aprendiendo teniendo todo
tipo de experiencias tropezando y
levantando nos una y otra vez
por eso nació la iniciativa para aportar
nuestro granito de arena devolviéndole a
la sociedad la posibilidad y nos dio
estudiar en un lugar como éste gratuito
como hay muy pocos lugares del mundo
[Música]
por eso yo pienso que la educación no
tiene por qué representar el mero éxito
personal de cada uno de nosotros sino
que puede significar una mejora para el
entorno que nos rodea como nos pasó con
leandro con martina y con tantas otras
historias este último año
para no salirme del ingeniero llamar me
gustaría tener una frase de isaac newton
un físico del siglo 17 que decía
construimos demasiados números y no
suficientes puentes yo creo que la
educación puede ser un puente que una
que transforme una realidad injusta
de igualdad de oportunidades en un mundo
que la práctica no los tiene
la oración
puedo unir personas sexuales que
parecían imposibles de unir
después de un año lleno de
emociones y aprendizajes yo creo que
sólo depende de nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
camagüey